Como otros conferenciantes han dicho, es una experiencia bastante intimidante -
una experiencia particularmente intimidante - hablar enfrente de esta audiencia.
Pero a diferencia de los demás, yo no les voy a hablar acerca
de los misterios del universo o de las maravillas de la evolución,
o de las maneras ingeniosas, innovadoras, en que se están atacando
las mayores desigualdades de nuestro mundo.
O incluso de los retos de las naciones en la economía global moderna.
Mi trabajo, como han oído, es hablarles de estadística --
y, para ser más preciso, contarles algunas cosas apasionantes acerca de ella.
Y eso es --
(Risas)
-- eso es bastante más difícil
que lo que han hecho todos los conferenciantes antes de mí y todos los que vengan después.
(Risas)
Uno de mis colegas me dijo, cuando yo era un novato en esta profesión,
orgullosamente, que los estadísticos eran personas a quienes les gustaban los números
pero no tenían la personalidad para ser contables.
(Risas)
Y hay otro chiste entre estadísticos que es:
“¿Cómo distingues al estadístico introvertido del estadístico extrovertido?
Cuya respuesta es,
“El estadístico extrovertido es el que mira los zapatos de la otra persona.”
(Risas)
Pero quiero decirles algo útil – y aquí está, así que concéntrense.
Esta tarde, hay una recepción en el Museo de Historia Natural de la Universidad.
Y es un lugar maravilloso, como espero que noten,
y un gran icono de lo mejor de la tradición victoriana.
Es muy improbable – en este lugar especial, con este grupo de gente --
pero puede ser que se encuentren hablando con alguien indeseable.
Así que aquí está lo que deben hacer.
Cuando les pregunten ”¿A qué se dedica?” Responden: “Soy estadístico”.
(Risas)
Bueno, excepto porque ahora están advertidos, y sabrán que se lo está inventando.
Entonces una de dos cosas pasará.
O descubrirán a un primo perdido en la otra esquina de la habitación
y correrán a hablar con él,
o de repente se sentirán sedientos y/o hambrientos – a menudo ambas--
y correrán a por un trago y algo de comida.
Y a usted lo dejarán en paz para hablar con la persona con quien realmente quería.
Es uno de los retos de nuestra profesión intentar explicar lo que hacemos.
No estamos en la cima de las listas de invitados a cenar, a charlar y a cosas así.
Y es algo que nunca he encontrado cómo hacer.
Pero mi esposa – entonces mi novia -
lo logró mucho mejor de lo que yo jamás he podido.
Hace muchos años, cuando empezábamos a salir, ella trabajaba para la BBC en Gran Bretaña,
y yo estaba, en ese momento, trabajando en Estados Unidos.
Yo estaba de vuelta visitándola.
Le dijo lo siguiente a una de sus compañeras de trabajo, quien preguntó: “¿Bien, qué es lo que hace tu novio?”
Sarah pensó bastante acerca de las cosas que yo le había explicado -
y se concentró, aquellos días, en escuchar.
(Risas)
No le digan que dije eso.
Y estaba pensando en el trabajo que yo hacía desarrollando modelos matemáticos
para comprender la evolución y la genética modernas.
Así que cuando su compañera le preguntó: “¿Qué hace?”
Ella hizo una pausa y dijo: “Modela cosas”.
(Risas)
Bueno, su compañera súbitamente se interesó mucho más de lo que cabía esperar
y siguió preguntando: “¿Qué es lo que modela?”
Bien, Sarah pensó un poco más acerca de mi trabajo y dijo: “Genes”.
(Risa)
"Modela genes”.
Este es mi primer amor, y de ello les voy a hablar un poco.
Lo que sobre todo quiero conseguir es que piensen acerca
del lugar que la incertidumbre, el azar y la probabilidad ocupan en nuestro mundo,
y cómo reaccionamos frente a ello, y que tan bien razonamos o no respecto a esto.
Así que lo han tenido bastante fácil hasta ahora --
algunas risas y cosas por el estilo – en las conferencias hasta ahora.
Tienen que pensar, y voy a hacerles algunas preguntas.
Así que aquí está el escenario de la primera pregunta que tengo:
¿Pueden imaginarse lanzando una moneda sucesivamente?
Y por alguna razón – la cual tendrá que quedar sin precisar --
estamos interesados en un patrón en particular.
Aquí hay uno: cara, seguida de cruz, seguida de otra cruz.
Así que supongan que lanzamos una moneda repetidamente.
Entonces la pauta cara-cruz-cruz, con la que nos hemos obsesionado, aparece.
Y pueden contar: uno, dos, tres, cuatro, cinco, seis, siete, ocho, nueve, diez --
ocurre después del décimo lanzamiento.
Deben de pensar que hay cosas más interesantes que hacer, pero síganme la corriente un momento.
Imagínense que cada uno en este lado de la audiencia saca una moneda y la lanza
hasta que logra el patrón cara-cruz-cruz.
La primera vez que lo hacen, tal vez pase después del décimo lanzamiento, como aquí.
La segunda vez, tal vez sea después del cuarto.
Y la próxima, después del decimoquinto.
Así que lanzan la moneda muchas, muchas veces, y calculan la media de esos números.
En eso es en lo que quiero que este lado piense.
El otro lado de la audiencia no quiere cara-cruz-cruz --
piensan que, por razones culturales, es aburrido --
y están mucho más interesados en otro patrón – cara-cruz-cara.
Así que en este lado, sacan sus monedas, y las lanzan y lanzan y lanzan.
Y cuentan los lanzamientos hasta que el patrón cara-cruz-cara aparece
y sacan la media. ¿De acuerdo?
Así que en este lado, tienen un número --
lo han hecho muchas veces, así que el número es preciso –
que es el número promedio de volados hasta conseguir cara-cruz-cruz.
En este lado, tienen otro número – el número promedio de lanzamientos hasta conseguir cara-cruz-cara.
Aquí encontramos un hecho matemático profundo --
si tienes dos números, una de tres cosas tiene que ocurrir.
O son iguales, o uno es más grande que el otro
o viceversa.
¿Así que qué está pasando aquí?
Todos ustedes tienen que pensarlo bien, y todos deben votar --
si no, no continuaremos.
Y no quiero terminar con un silencio de dos minutos
para darles tiempo para pensarlo, hasta que todos expresen una opinión. Vale.
Lo que tienen que hacer es comparar el número promedio de lanzamientos hasta que conseguimos
cara-cruz-cara con el número promedio de lanzamientos hasta que conseguimos cara-cruz-cruz.
¿Quién cree que A es verdad --
que en promedio, tomará más tiempo ver cara-cruz-cara que cara-cruz-cruz?
¿Quién cree que B es verdad – que el promedio es igual?
¿Quién cree que C es verdad – que en promedio, tomará menos tiempo
ver cara-cruz-cara que cara-cruz-cruz?
Vale, ¿quién queda por votar? Porque eso es una travesura – dije que tenían que votar.
(Risas)
Vale. La mayoría cree que B es verdad.
Y les tranquilizará saber que incluso matemáticos bastante distinguidos piensan lo mismo.
Pero no lo es. A es verdad.
Tarda más tiempo, de media.
De hecho, el número promedio de lanzamientos hasta cara-cruz-cara es 10,
y la media hasta cara-cruz-cruz es 8.
¿Cómo puede ser esto?
¿Hay alguna diferencia entre los dos patrones?
La hay. Cara-cruz-cara se solapa.
Si buscas cara-cruz-cara, con suerte puedes conseguir dos secuencias
del patrón en cinco lanzamientos.
Eso no lo puedes hacer con cara-cruz-cruz.
Y eso resulta ser importante.
Hay dos maneras de pensar acerca de esto.
Les mostraré una de ellas.
Imaginen – supongamos que lo estamos haciendo.
De este lado – recuerden, están entusiasmados con cara-cruz-cruz --
y ustedes están entusiasmados con cara-cruz-cara.
Lanzamos la moneda, y sale cara --
y están al borde de su asiento
porque algo grandioso y maravilloso, o increíble, puede estar a punto de suceder.
El siguiente lanzamiento sale cruz — están realmente entusiasmados.
El champán está metido en el hielo a su lado, y tienen las copas heladas listas para celebrar.
Esperan con el corazón en la mano el último lanzamiento.
Y si sale cara, es grandioso.
Lo lograron, y lo celebran.
Si sale cruz – bueno, es decepcionante, guardan las copas
y ponen el champán en su lugar.
Y siguen lanzando, esperando la siguiente cara, para entusiasmarse.
En este lado, la experiencia es diferente.
Es igual durante las primeras dos partes de la secuencia.
Están un poco entusiasmados con la primera cara --
y bastante más con la siguiente cruz.
Entonces lanzan la moneda.
Si es cruz, abren el champán.
Si es cara, están algo decepcionados,
pero ya tienen una tercera parte de su patrón.
Y esa es una manera informal de presentarlo – pero esa es la diferencia.
Otra manera de verlo -
si lanzamos la moneda ocho millones de veces,
esperaríamos un millón de cara-cruz-cara
y un millón de cara-cruz-cruz – pero las cara-cruz-cruz podrían ocurrir en conjunto.
Así que si ponen un millón de cosas entre ocho millones de posiciones
y pueden permitir algo de traslape, los conjuntos estarán más lejos entre sí.
Esa es otra manera de intuirlo.
¿Qué es lo que quiero decir?
Es un ejemplo muy, muy simple, una pregunta sencilla de probabilidad,
que absolutamente – y están en buena compañía – todos responden mal.
Este es mi pequeño entretenimiento en relación con mi pasión verdadera, que es la genética.
Hay una relación entre cara-cruz-cara y cara-cruz-cruz en la genética,
y es la siguiente.
Cuando lanzas una moneda, obtienes una secuencia de caras y cruces.
Cuando vemos el ADN, hay una secuencia de no solo dos cosas – caras y cruces --
sino de cuatro letras — A, G, C y T.
Y hay unas pequeñas tijeras químicas, llamadas enzimas de restricción
que cortan el ADN cuando ven un cierto patrón.
Y son una herramienta enormemente útil en la biología molecular moderna.
Y en vez de preguntar: “¿Cuántos lanzamientos hasta conseguir cara-cruz-cara?” --
podemos preguntar: “¿Cómo de grandes serán los pedazos cuando uso una enzima de restricción
que corta cuando ve, por ejemplo, G-A-A-G?”
¿Cómo de largos serán esos pedazos?
Esa es una conexión algo trivial entre la probabilidad y la genética.
Hay una conexión mucho más profunda, pero no tengo tiempo para explorarla
y es que la genética moderna es un área realmente excitante de la ciencia.
Y oiremos algunas charlas más tarde específicamente acerca de esto.
Pero resulta que descubriendo los secretos en la información producida por tecnologías
experimentales modernas, una parte clave tiene que ver con bastante sofisticados --
estarán felices de saber que hago algo útil en mi trabajo diario,
más sofisticado que la historia de la cara-cruz-cruz --
con modelos computacionales y matemáticos bastante sofisticados
y técnicas estadísticas modernas.
Y les voy a dar dos pequeños fragmentos – dos ejemplos --
de proyectos que lleva mi grupo en Oxford,
los cuales creo que son bastante apasionantes.
Ustedes han oído hablar acerca del Proyecto del Genoma Humano.
Fue un proyecto que intentaba descifrar una copia del genoma humano.
Lo que sigue naturalmente después de lograrlo --
es este otro proyecto, el Proyecto Internacional HapMap,
el cual es una colaboración entre laboratorios de cinco o seis países.
Piensen que en el Proyecto del Genoma Humano se trata de aprender qué tenemos en común,
y el proyecto HapMap intenta entender
dónde están las diferencias entre las distintas personas.
¿Por qué nos importa?
Bueno, hay muchas razones.
La más urgente es que queremos entender cómo es que algunas diferencias
hacen a algunas personas propensas a cierta enfermedad –como la diabetes del tipo 2 --
y otras diferencias hacen a ciertas personas más propensas a las enfermedades cardíacas,
o a las apoplejías, o al autismo, etcétera.
Ese es un gran proyecto.
Hay otro gran proyecto,
recientemente financiado por el Wellcome Trust en este país,
involucrando grandes estudios –
miles de individuos, con ocho enfermedades diferentes,
enfermedades comunes como la diabetes del tipo 1 y 2, enfermedades coronarias,
trastorno bipolar, y otras – para intentar entender la genética.
Para intentar entender qué diferencias genéticas y por qué causan las enfermedades.
¿Por qué queremos hacerlo?
Porque entendemos muy poco acerca de la mayoría de las enfermedades humanas.
No sabemos qué las causa.
Y si podemos llegar al fondo y entender la genética,
tendremos una ventana al modo de actuación de la enfermedad.
Y una manera completamente nueva de ver las terapias
y el tratamiento preventivo y todo lo demás.
Así que ese es, como dije, el pequeño entretenimiento dentro de mi verdadero amor.
De vuelta a consideraciones más mundanas sobre nuestro razonamiento con la incertidumbre.
Aquí hay otro acertijo para ustedes --
supongan que tenemos una prueba para detectar una enfermedad.
No es infalible, pero es bastante buena.
Acierta el 99% de las veces.
Y tomo a uno de ustedes o a alguien al azar en la calle,
y les hago esta prueba de la enfermedad.
Supongamos que es una prueba para el VIH – el virus que causa el SIDA --
y la prueba dice que la persona está enferma.
¿Cuál es la probabilidad de que la tenga?
La prueba acierta el 99% de las veces.
Así que la respuesta natural es 99%.
¿A quién le gusta esa respuesta?
Vamos – todos tenemos que participar.
No crean que ya no pueden confiar en mí.
(Risas)
Bien, está bien que se sientan un poco escépticos, porque esa no es la respuesta.
Es lo que podrían pensar.
No es la respuesta, y no lo es porque es sólo una parte de la historia.
En realidad, depende de que tan común sea la enfermedad.
Déjenme intentar mostrárselo.
Tenemos una muestra de un millón de individuos.
Así que pensemos en una enfermedad que afecta --
es bastante rara, afecta a una persona de cada 10,000.
En este millón de individuos, la mayoría están sanos
y algunos tendrán la enfermedad.
De hecho, si esta es la frecuencia de la enfermedad,
alrededor de 100 tendrán la enfermedad y el resto no.
Ahora supongamos que le hacemos la prueba a todos.
¿Qué ocurre?
Bueno, entre los 100 que tienen la enfermedad,
la prueba acertará el 99% de las veces, y 99 saldrán positivos.
Entre todas las personas que no tienen la enfermedad,
la prueba acertará el 99% de las veces.
Solamente se equivocará un 1% de veces.
Pero hay tantos que habrá un número enorme de falsos positivos.
Poniéndolo de otra manera --
de todo aquel que resulte positivo – aquí están, los individuos involucrados --
menos de uno de cada 100 tendrá realmente la enfermedad.
Así que aún si pensamos que la prueba es precisa, la parte importante de la historia es
que hay otra información necesaria.
Esta es la intuición clave.
Lo que tenemos que hacer, una vez que sabemos que la prueba es positiva
es considerar la plausibilidad, o probabilidad, de dos explicaciones que compiten.
Cada una de esas explicaciones tiene una parte probable y una parte improbable.
Una explicación es que la persona no tiene la enfermedad --
lo que es abrumadoramente probable, si tomas a alguien al azar --
pero la prueba se equivoca, lo que es improbable.
La otra explicación es que la persona está enferma – lo que es improbable --
pero la prueba es correcta, lo que es probable.
Y el número con el que nos encontramos --
ese número que es un poco menos del 1% --
tiene que ver con qué tan probable una de esas explicaciones es relativa a la otra.
Cada una en conjunto es improbable.
Aquí hay un ejemplo de más actualidad que trata exactamente de lo mismo.
Quienes sean de Gran Bretaña sabrán acerca de un caso que se ha hecho bastante famoso
de una mujer llamada Sally Clark, que tuvo dos bebés que murieron súbitamente.
Inicialmente, se pensó que murieron de lo que informalmente se llama “muerte en la cuna”,
y más formalmente Síndrome de Muerte Súbita Infantil.
Por varias razones, se la acusó de asesinato.
Y en el juicio, su juicio, un pediatra muy distinguido aportó evidencia
de que la probabilidad de dos muertes en la cuna, muertes inocentes, en una familia como la suya --
profesional y no fumadora – era de una en 73 millones.
En resumen, fue condenada en esa ocasión.
Después, recientemente, fue declarada inocente al apelar – de hecho, en su segunda apelación.
Y solo para ponerlo en contexto, pueden imaginar qué horrible es para alguien
si es inocente, perder un hijo, y luego otro,
y ser condenada por asesinarlos.
Soportar todo el estrés del juicio, de la condena por asesinarlos --
y pasar tiempo en una prisión de mujeres, donde todas las demás prisioneras
creen que mataste a tus hijos – es algo tremendamente horrible para una persona.
Y pasó en gran parte porque el experto se equivocó terriblemente
en las estadísticas, de dos maneras.
Así que, ¿de dónde sacó el número de uno en 73 millones?
Consultó algunas investigaciones que decían que la probabilidad de una muerte en cuna
en una familia como la de Sally Clark es aproximadamente de una en 8500.
Así que dijo “Supondré que si hay una muerte en la cuna en la familia,
las probabilidades de una segunda muerte no cambian”.
Eso es lo que los estadísticos llamarían una suposición de independencia.
Es como decir, “Si lanzas una moneda y sale cara a la primera,
no afectará a la posibilidad de sacar cara la segunda vez”.
Así que si lanzas una moneda dos veces, las posibilidades de sacar cara dos veces es la mitad --
eso es la posibilidad de la primera vez – por la mitad – la posibilidad de la segunda vez.
Así que dijo, “Asumamos --
Asumiré que estos eventos son independientes.
Cuando multiplicas 8500 por 8500,
da cerca de 73 millones.”
Y nada de esto se expuso al tribunal como una suposición
o se presentó al jurado de esa manera.
Desafortunadamente – y de verdad, lamentablemente --
primero que nada, en esta situación tendrías que verificarlo empíricamente.
Y segundo, es palpablemente falso.
Hay muchas cosas que no sabemos con respecto a la muerte súbita infantil.
Puede que afecten factores ambientales que no conocemos,
y es muy probable que también haya
factores genéticos que no conocemos.
Así que si una familia sufre una muerte en la cuna, la pondrías en un grupo de alto riesgo.
Probablemente tengan factores de riesgo ambientales
y/o genéticos que no conocemos.
Y argumentar, entonces, que la posibilidad de una segunda muerte es igual que si desconocieras
esa información, es realmente estúpido.
Es peor que estúpido – es ciencia realmente mala.
Sin embargo, así fue presentada, y en el juicio ni siquiera nadie lo discutió.
Ese es el primer problema.
El segundo problema es, ¿qué significa el número de uno en 73 millones?
Así que después de que Sally Clark fuera condenada --
pueden imaginar, el efecto notable en la prensa --
uno de los periodistas de uno de los periódicos más respetables de Gran Bretaña escribió que
lo que el experto dijo fue:
“La probabilidad de que sea inocente es de una en 73 millones.”
Ese es un error lógico.
Es exactamente el mismo error lógico que el error de pensar que
después de la prueba de la enfermedad, que es un 99% precisa,
la posibilidad de tener la enfermedad es del 99%.
En el ejemplo de la enfermedad, teníamos que tener en cuenta dos cosas,
una de las cuales era la posibilidad de que la prueba se equivocara.
Y otra era la posibilidad, a priori, de que la persona tuviera la enfermedad o no.
Es exactamente igual en este contexto.
Hay dos cosas involucradas – dos partes de la explicación.
Queremos saber qué tan probables, o qué tan relativamente probables, son dos explicaciones.
Una de ellas es que Sally Clark era inocente --
que es, a priori, abrumadoramente posible --
la mayoría de las madres no matan a sus hijos.
Y la segunda parte de la explicación
es que le pasó algo increíblemente improbable.
No tan improbable como uno en 73 millones, pero muy improbable de todas formas.
La otra explicación es que era culpable.
Probablemente pensamos a priori que es improbable.
Y así deberíamos pensar en el contexto de un juicio criminal,
que es improbable, debido a la presunción de inocencia.
Y entonces si ella hubiera intentado matar a sus hijos, lo logró.
Así que la probabilidad de que sea inocente no es una en 73 millones.
No sabemos cual es.
Tiene que ver con sopesar la contundencia de la evidencia en su contra
y la evidencia estadística.
Sabemos que los niños murieron.
Lo que importa es que tan probable o improbable, relativamente
son las dos explicaciones.
Ambas son inverosímiles.
Esta es una situación donde los errores en la estadística tuvieron profundas
y verdaderamente desafortunadas consecuencias.
De hecho, otras dos mujeres fueron condenadas en función de
la evidencia de dicho pediatra, y han sido posteriormente liberadas al apelar.
Muchos casos fueron revisados.
Y es de un verdadero interés actual porque ahora mismo está bajo cargos de descrédito
en el Consejo Médico General de Gran Bretaña.
Así que para concluir -- ¿Cuál es el mensaje de todo esto?
Bien, sabemos que el azar, la probabilidad y la incertidumbre
son parte integral de nuestra vida diaria.
Es también verdad – y aunque ustedes, como colectivo, son muy especiales de muchas maneras,
son completamente típicos en no acertar en los ejemplos que mencioné.
Está muy bien documentado el que la gente se equivoca en estas cosas.
Cometen errores de lógica al razonar con la incertidumbre.
Podemos trabajar con las sutilezas del idioma brillantemente --
y hay preguntas sobre cómo evolucionamos hasta lograrlo muy interesantes.
No somos buenos razonando con la incertidumbre.
Ese es un problema en nuestra vida diaria.
Como han oído en muchas de las charlas, la estadística está en la base de una gran cantidad
de la investigación científica – en ciencias sociales, medicina,
y de hecho, en buena parte de la industria.
Todo ese control de calidad, que tiene un gran impacto en el proceso industrial,
está basado en la estadística.
Es algo que hacemos mal.
Al menos, deberíamos reconocerlo, pero tendemos a no hacerlo.
Volviendo al contexto legal, en el caso del juicio de Sally Clark,
todos los abogados simplemente aceptaron las palabras del experto.
Así que si un pediatra le hubiera dicho a un jurado,
“Sé como construir puentes. Construí uno en esa calle.
Por favor crúcelo con su automóvil”,
el jurado habría dicho: “Los pediatras no saben construir puentes.
Eso les correponde a los ingenieros.”
Por otra parte, llegó y efectivamente dijo, o dió a entender,
“Sé como razonar con la incertidumbre. Sé trabajar con la estadística.”
Y todos dijeron: “Está bien. Es un experto”.
Así que tenemos que entender dónde acaban nuestras competencias.
Exactamente este tipo de cuestiones aparecieron cuando se empezaba a secuenciar el ADN,
cuando los científicos, los abogados y a veces incluso los jueces,
tergiversaron las pruebas sistemáticamente .
Normalmente – uno espera – que inocentemente, pero tergiversaron las pruebas.
Los científicos forenses dijeron, “La posibilidad de que este tipo sea inocente es una en 3 millones”.
Aun si te crees el número, igual que el de uno en 73 millones,
no es eso lo que significa.
Y ha habido apelaciones famosas
en Gran Bretaña y en otros lugares debido a eso.
Y para terminar con el contexto del sistema legal.
Está muy bien decir “Hagamos lo mejor para presentar las pruebas”.
Pero cada vez más, en los casos de análisis de ADN – este es otro --
esperamos que los jurados, que son gente corriente --
y estando documentado que son muy malos en esto --
esperamos que los jurados sean capaces de trabajar con este tipo de razonamiento.
En otras esferas de la vida, si la gente argumentara – bueno, con la excepción de la política.
Pero en otras esferas de la vida, si la gente argumentara ilógicamente,
diríamos que no es bueno.
Lo esperamos de los políticos y no esperamos mucho más.
En el caso de la incertidumbre, siempre nos estamos equivocando --
y al menos, deberíamos ser conscientes de ello.
E idealmente, tal vez deberíamos intentar hacer algo al respecto.
Muchas gracias.